la gaine donne qui fabrique des
ceintures de chasteté
était la seule personne en angleterre à
faire ça je suis pas sûr même à
terre-neuve sauver n'y a pas beaucoup de
gens qui font ça je pense pas
et en france on en fait
c'est possible j'en vois en france
d'enfants combien par an en france
depuis
l'année dernière c'était la première
fois que j'en vois des enfants j'en ai
vendu une cinquantaine
je crois que ça va continuer les gens
l'air intéressé
c'est à quoi comme clients
j'ai pas jours à des magasins
short ayew s'est revêtu les ventes des
magasins les gens vont les acheter en
magasin c'est ça ma cheese et ça coûte
combien
pour une ceinture comme ça faut compter
livres c'est vrai ça fait à peu près
2000 2000 francs quoi
est ce que tu peux nous expliquer
comment ça marche ça se met autour de la
taille de la femme
ouais c'est la ceinture puis ça s'ouvre
avec une plaie et je suppose qu'on
pourrait appeler ça l'entregent que tu
vois ça s'en va et cette partie souhait
et vient autour de la taille
il en faut être masque pour entrer là
dedans ouais sa vie autour de la taille
cette partie sera pas entre les jambes
et on verrouille la
louve qu'est ce qui se passe si on perd
la clé ah ben c'est un verrou de
sécurité ya plus qu elle suicidée
es-tu lund qui si on perd la clé un
objet de se suicider
il ya plusieurs types de ceinture de
chasteté
non il ya une version un peu plus légère
que celle ci met enfin le principe c'est
le même a c'est que la partie métallique
qui est plus légère si tu veux
mais c'est un peu lourd ça oui c'est un
modèle notre sécurité
n'est pas en commentant une femme peut
l'apporter
je sais pas moi je dirais quelques
semaines qui nous est pas plus
mais tout est possible ainsi de l'acier
inoxydable ça sera impossible de la
casser toute façon
il ce flux un ami nukem caisse lui dise
non
et une fois qu'il s'est passé pour elle
c'est légal
absolument
du moment que la personne qui la porte
est d'accord
du monde que la femme est d'accord way
sans qu'elles soient d'accord tant fait
pour les mecs et ouais c'est la même à
l'envers
il transpire pas vraiment non
un modèle spécial c'est plus compliqué
est ce qu'avec le sida augmente et on
chiffre d'affaires
c'est difficile à dire en fait j'en sais
j'en sais pas grand chose
hugo n'a pas senti un boom dans le
marché non je crois pas non
c'est très spécialisés mais commente on
est arrivé à fabriquer des trucs comme
ça
au départ ça m'intéressait
deux soldats a
[Musique]
en fait j'allais écrire un livre
là-dessus et plus j'avançais dans mes
recherches plus ça m'a fasciné plus est
devenu complexe c'est un sujet très
compliqué de ça on trouve difficilement
des statistiques
[Musique]
qu'est ce tu les tests
j'ai fait des tests de marché
mais tu fais des essais sur des femmes
oui pour concevoir et bonnel bien sur
wii
et du cancer la maison et ta femme par
exemple à thé à paris tu ne fais mes
trucs avant de partir
non non
je trouve que c'est un peu moyenâgeux
comme truc
moi je suis pas dans une croisade un
studio je répands la demande il ya de la
demande j'en fabrique c'est tout haut
mais qu'en même temps fait 50 pour la
france mais dans le monde entier
je sais pas 200 parents ont fait
l'unanimité par le nombre que je peux
produire mais je pense qu'avec une bonne
campagne de pub à grande échelle il s'en
vend pas un maximum
ainsi quand j'ai froid pétange et moi
devant le congrès
alors moi
tu crois que c'est un marché qui va se
développer
[Musique]
c'est difficile à dire c'est un objet
qu'on trouve pas facilement quand les
gens on trouve c'est à partir d'une
publicité de bouche à oreille
[Musique]
douze essais leur fait mal aux femmes de
porter ça
l on souffre pas
non je pense que toute façon la plupart
sont d'accord faut savoir que 75 % des
gens pour montrer qu'elles sont fidèles
oui et puis 75% des rapports un peu
style sado maso et vivent ça comme leurs
fantasmes elle essaie d'en faire la
réalité c'est leur truc
je dirais que 75 % des clients font
partie de ces gens là je dirais que la
plupart sont consentantes
les favelas
ah bon
sa maman spéciale et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu